thank you
welcome everybody good to see you
I'm Alexander Rosen the executive
director here at long now and I want to
just a couple quick reminders uh turn
off things in your pocket that make
noise uh I know it's maybe been a while
since many of you've been in rooms with
other people but uh if you can turn
those off that would be great
um it's really amazing to be back here
at SF Jazz for a large venue talk and
thank you all for coming out give
yourselves a round of applause
uh and we have a few uh new staff that
hopefully you'll get to meet we have a
new CEO Rebecca lendell is she in this
room somewhere she can wave and anyway
she's probably she's probably working in
front uh and Mikko uh who's our new
director of development and James home
who's worked with us for decades has now
our head of uh Communications so I want
to welcome them and our our amazing
staff that's been doing events through
the whole pandemic and uh and are now
kind of getting back into the rhythm of
doing these things I just want to thank
them as well as we as we get started the
um we are going to have a long short
tonight which some of you remember as a
short film uh that somehow exemplifies
long-term thinking on the theme of of
what we're talking about and tonight's
is one we're actually bringing back from
a very long time ago that's a a really
beautiful study uh kind of inspired by
Jenny's work of of what you can observe
by just looking you know straight up in
the sky uh and it's really an
observation of this guy over here and
it's it's a beautiful one so I'll just
give a short intro and then that's Gonna
Roll all right before a Jenny comes up
but I first met Jenny O'Dell I think
when she was uh The Artisan Residence at
the uh what people call the SF dump or
the landfill and it was you know she was
doing these insane collages and really
great Observatory work on what we often
think of as trash or what we what we
often think of as the mundane and she
has she's kind of made a career now out
of observing the things right around
herself and I believe the the proposal
for this book was done before uh before
the the pandemic but of course the
pandemic made for a perfect moment to
observe the things closest to us and so
it's been amazing to kind of watch her
career and uh and and make a a real
study out of that and I started reading
this new book after reading her last one
and I just started underlining so much
of it that I I just asked her I was like
can you just read the beginning of the
intro as you're reading because it's so
uh apropos to long now and I think is a
perfect setup for the conversation and
the rest of her talk that we're going to
have tonight so I believe that's what
she's about to do and with that I'll
leave you with our long short and Jenny
Odell thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
hi
um that was so beautiful I'm so glad
that we could start with that
um thank you so much for being here
thank you to the long now for hosting me
and besides the fact that there's a lot
of overlap between what I write about in
my book and the type of thinking that
the long now does
um this event is really meaningful for
me because uh my work is very based in
the Bay Area and this is the Bay Area
Institution
um this is also only the third in-person
event I've done since the beginning of
the pandemic
um so I'm just so glad that we could all
be here together
um
I I'm going to talk a little bit about
how the book came to be and what's in it
um but before I get to that I am I will
read a little bit of the introduction
just as a way in
okay
at some point in the spring of 2019 I
noticed that my apartment had received
some unexpected visitors
they likely arrived not through the door
but through the window and for a long
time I didn't know they were there it
was not until I happened to see the
fronds of a mosque growing in a
pig-shaped ceramic planter next to the
window that I had any idea we'd been
invaded
the Moss boards took up residence around
a tiny bunny ear cactus a friend who's
here
um given me for my birthday years
earlier
I'd always hated how cold and damp the
area next to my kitchen window was it
never gets any sun and the cactus
probably did too but the moss found it
hospitable
it's set about dividing differentiating
grabbing hold of the potting soil with
hair like rhizoids and growing tiny
green leaves
then it sent up long slender sporophytes
ready to continue the same process as
its ancestors outside the apartment
soon a miniature forest was fairly
bursting from the top of the pig
compared to vascular plants mosses have
a relatively unmediated relationship to
Water and Air
in her book Gathering Moss Robin wall
kimmerer notes that the one celsic
leaves of mosses are like the alveoli of
human lungs given that they require
moisture and come into direct contact
with air
on Antarctica which has no trees
scientists have used mosses in a similar
manner to tree rings the Mosses are
capable of laying down a record each
summer because of the way their leaves
take in chemicals from the surroundings
growing from their tips
sitting in my kitchen I obviously could
not read the record that this errant
Moss was writing but it did at least
tell me I'm alive and the next day still
alive
I reread Gathering Moss during the early
lockdowns of the covid-19 pandemic
time felt Frozen then but the Moss kept
growing both inside and outside the
apartment and the pandemic had Shrunk
the scale of my attention
I walked around Oakland like a
pedestrian conspiracy theorist peering
at things from odd angles
Moss loved the interstices which meant
it was often exactly where I wouldn't
think to look between cracks in the
walkway outside my apartment between the
asphalt of the road and the manhole
cover between the grocery store wall and
the sidewalk between bricks
I came to understand Moss as the
signature of water both in placement and
appearance as it grew wherever water had
collected in the past but it also
answered the rain in real time expanding
and turning Greener within minutes of a
light shower
the Moss made me consider both very
short time scales like the minute to
minute changes in moisture or the moment
of a Spore growing in my planter and
very long evolutionary time scales as
mosses were some of the very first
plants to live on land
yet both ends of the temporal Spectrum
were also reminders of how impossible it
is to pinpoint a moment a very human
thing to want to do
on one end for example I found
disagreement about when a mossport has
officially germinated is it when it has
become swollen with water to a certain
degree or when the germ tube forms and
the cell cell wall ruptures
on the other hand the earliest mosses
evolved from aquatic algae at some point
hundreds of millions of years ago but it
would be absurd to try to identify the
exact moment of this Innovation or even
the speciation of the guest on my
windowsill
this slipperiness easily spilled over
into other questions
could a moss be meaningfully separated
from its surroundings
was a moss Spore considered alive
what about a moss that was frozen like
the one in Antarctica that was brought
back to life after 1500 years
even outside extreme conditions mosses
complicate the idea of uniform time with
the ability of some species to go
dormant for more than a decade without
water
under the right circumstances they will
revive
it was this very quality as Cameron
mentioned in a 2020 interview in the
believer that made Moss especially worth
paying attention to during the covid-19
pandemic noting that her students took
inspiration from Ross Ross's rootedness
and dormancy camera suggested that these
plants could teach humans how to inhabit
this historical moment
the Moss arrived in my apartment around
the time I started thinking about this
book it was still growing when I
finished
true it probably will not live in that
spot for 5 000 years as has one moth
shelf on Elephant Island also in
Antarctica
but in the long mean time it has taken
in three years of sunlight breezed three
years of air and witnessed three years
of me at the kitchen table
like an emissary from somewhere outside
clock time it has populated my mind with
questions of porousness and response of
inside and outside of potentiality and
imminence
most of all it has been a reminder of
time not the monolithic empty substance
imagined to wash over each of us alone
but the kind that starts and stops
bubbles up collects in the cracks and
folds into mountains
it is the kind that waits for the right
conditions that holds always the ability
to begin something new
so that's the very beginning of the book
um
thank you
and since you all have a copy it's very
Mossy lately so hopefully you will be
noticing loss
um
so uh this book published today which
means I've been doing a lot of
interviews and one of the questions that
I get asked is why I chose to write
about time
and I've been finding it a little bit
hard to answer that because I don't feel
like I ever really chose it or I don't
remember choosing it
um perhaps the best way to explain my
choice is with this image from the
photographer Alan grinberg who lives in
Pacifica and was kind enough to let me
use this in uh my conclusion in the book
um he took this during the king Tides a
couple years ago
so I wrote this book for the same reason
that I wrote how to do nothing which is
that I needed it
um in this case as a person who feels
crushed by the pressure between now and
not now
it's true that I have a cerebral
interest in time I think most of us do
but with that alone I never would have
written this I never would have tried to
write my way out of a bind that felt
very real
this book is my sincere attempt to
recover an appetite for the future and
someone who lives squeezed between Daily
Times scarcity climate Despair and the
knowledge of their own mortality
uh in in the introduction I call it my
panoramic assault on nihilism
um so and the title saving time is a
double meaning I want to think through
how more people can have more time by
which I really mean more control over
their time
um but I also want to think about saving
senses of time
um the same way you would think of a
seed bank
and one very significant sense of time
that I want to save is time that's not
simply additive but alchemical where no
moment is the same and each is capable
of transfiguring the past all at once
and In This Moment In which so much
seems deadening and inevitable it's that
quality of possibility that I'm trying
to save
um so I said that my work is based in
the Bay area that is more literally the
case with this book than how to do
nothing I organized the book chapterwise
as a one day out and back road trip from
Oakland to the Pacific coast and back
um and then each of the chapters is set
in a location where that type of time or
understanding of time is especially
visible
um so just to run through them really
quickly uh the industrial time I talk
about at the Oakland port
problems with time management self-help
and a traffic jam on 880 probably very
familiar to some of you I feel like
people in New York will not understand
that um
a Leisure at the Stanford Shopping
Center and a nearby Open Space Preserve
ecological and geological time at a
beach in Pescadero
climate dread at the part of Pacifica
that is especially hard hit by erosion
uh different communal languages of time
at the prelinger library
um oops sorry and uh the finally the
time of one's own life I.E mortality at
the Chapel of the Chimes and its
neighboring Cemetery
um and in doing this I'm making use of a
very old story technology one where it's
easier to remember the different parts
of the story later if you can travel the
root in your head so like cynically I'm
just trying to help you remember what's
in the book but
um I also wanted it to be a trip where
you returned to the beginning because
I'm very obsessed with the feeling of
returning to something with new
knowledge a process that also represents
time and the fact that we are always
learning and experiencing even if we
think we're in the same place
um and I also did this to show the
reader that we can easily find material
evidence of the seemingly abstract and
historical ideas I'm describing
um that we can find them in the concrete
every day uh that time and history have
made the material and cultural world we
live in and that by extension what we do
now is historical
so I don't have time tonight to take you
on this entire road trip
um I thought I would just drop into a
couple of points along the way and
hopefully inspire you to take the entire
Journey on your own
um so as I said the very first chapter
begins at 7 A.M at the Oakland Port
um and so they're sort of like
italicized interludes in the book that
imagine that you and I are in my car
from high school
which has no AUX input or power windows
or anything it's just your just a car
um so and that we're like you know
driving through the Oakland Port
thinking about industrial time
um I chose the setting because it gives
us such a striking view of
standardization standardization and by
extension it's kind of a visual metaphor
for how time appears when we think of
time as money
um like the container system the
standardization of time and the notion
of equal interchangeable hours that
could be run through a system happened
in a very specific moment involving
Commerce colonialism and the need to
measure others labor
and I think it's worthwhile keeping this
history in mind when we consider the
current stickiness of the notion that
time is money
there's a really incredible book called
the colonization of time by Giordano
Nani that I cite quite a bit of in that
chapter where he describes the encounter
between the British colonial sense of
time and the existing understandings of
time among people living in colonized
places and this encounter was not a
straightforward takeover you get
situations where for example the Sabbath
punctuated week only extends as far as
the audible range of the Mission Bell
um but I want to read a little excerpt
that Nanny Nani gives us from the late
from a late 19th century publication
it's from a South African Mission and
it's essentially a piece of cultural
propaganda about time
okay it says
how much have you in the bank not the
Savings Bank that would be a good thing
for you to have a little there too this
bank is a better one perhaps you have
nothing to put in the Savings Bank and
you think you have nothing to put in any
other you are wrong you may be putting
money in every day did you ever count up
how much or how little you had got there
in the Bank of which God is the manager
and over whose counter past the
well-used moments of each day and all
the good things a man thinks or says or
does we speak of spending time time
spent does not go into the bank any more
than money spent but every money every
moment you use well for god you put into
the bank I would advise you to all to
put something in to put in all you can
for the bank gives good interest
um so I think this excerpt kind of gives
you some idea of how deeply the notion
of time as money is tied to pretty
specific ideas about Labor morality and
and this idea of taming the uncivilized
um
in tracing this history I also cite the
work of Caitlin Rosenthal who has
researched early examples of what we
would Now call spreadsheets including
pre-printed ones that were used to
record the labor of people enslaved on
American and Caribbean plantations and
for Rosenthal there is an uncomfortable
link between this history and modern
management practices
um in an interview with the Harvard
Business Review she pointed out that
many of the men running these
plantations were absentee owners they
lived overseas
and she says uh quote so you imagine
them in London getting reports in the
mail about their plantations and just
crunching the numbers over lunch not so
different from Modern board members it's
so easy for someone at a long distance
to forget about the humanity of the
labor
um and then of course this abstraction
of time and measurement of Labor
continued with taylorism and Factory
labor a way of measuring and
systematizing work to make it go faster
this graphic is from an article called
the stopwatch as inventor in a 1916
issue of factory magazine and you can
see how minutely the work is broken down
into separate timed actions and this is
my personal favorite uh this is from
Harry braverman's book where he's
looking at scientific office management
and this is them timing how long it
takes a bunch of time hard
Sperry meta um
also have what does identify card I
don't know anyway
um
so in these examples uh what you find is
that the history of time management well
certainly Innovative has so often been
inextricable from the desire to get more
labor out of people in less time
um for his part Taylor had hoped that
workers would share in the increased
productivity but that unfortunately is
not what seems to have happened
um and meanwhile it continues to morph
into new oppressive forms
to some of us something like taylorism
sounds like something of the industrial
past but it wouldn't to anyone who uses
a scanner gun in an Amazon warehouse
works in a call center that uses
motivational leaderboards drives the UPS
truck fitted with sensors or Works
remotely on a computer that uses
employee tracking software unironically
named staff cop this is Staff cop
um
yeah
so I end the chapter by comparing the
moment my one of my favorite movie
moments ever uh in Charlie Chaplin's
modern times where he's strapped into a
feeding machine designed to eliminate
the factory lunch hour and he's like
abused by this corn cob going into his
face
um with uh kg matsuda's 2019 360 degree
short film merger in which the lone
character is struggling to keep up with
her work interface and an evil version
of Microsoft's clippy which you can see
in the background there
um
she tells us there isn't always time to
eat but there are so many innovative
ways to fuel your body and mind
so besides its survival into the present
the other reason to revisit this history
is that it makes it easier to see the
ways in which we've internalized this
very specific industrial sense of time
um this is from increasing personal
efficiency of prillinger Library find
um and it's a 1925 book that attempts to
very literally apply Taylor's principles
to one's own life and thinking so in
this view you are both Factory owner and
Factory and the hours of your life are
your material
and I trace this also to the present
specifically to a group of content
creators I refer to in the book as
productivity Bros
um
this is an image of a product called the
Mastery Journal where you are evidently
both master and mastered
logging your progress on 10-day
productivity charts
so these and other forms of time
management show that the idea is very
much still alive that everyone has 24
fungible hours in a day and that those
who fall behind simply aren't using them
in the right way and that furthermore
life is a zero-sum game where my getting
ahead can only mean you're falling
behind
instead beyond the basic psychological
variation in how time feels the shape of
your hours and days so often depends on
the same things that govern the
landscape of power in our society
Financial latitude race gender ability
zip code number of children and other
circumstantial factors from the distance
you live from your work to relationships
or lack thereof to neighbors to your
company or country's sick leave policies
one of the people I spoke to for this
book is an admin for a working mom's
Facebook group and I thought it was very
telling that rather than follow the
advice of time management self-help
which she compared to the financial
advice to just not buy that latte
she thought it might be a better idea to
get six other moms together and have
each one of them make dinner for
everyone else one night of the week
already a task already a tacit
acknowledgment of the social nature of
time
as long as we continue to subscribe to
this notion of individuals with fungible
hours and their individual time Banks
it's harder for us to imagine this kind
of collective liberating of time whether
it's in the hard sense of Labor
organizing and policy interventions or
in the soft sense of how we talk to each
other about time
when we remove the grid and the calendar
from time which I simply understand is
change and a series of interconnected
processes the temporal landscape turns
out to be incredibly rich but the
Primacy of this landscape can be a
really hard thing to grasp in chapter
four I present this graph of Sundial
time versus standardized clock time
and I write the graph shows both
readings of time yet they are not equal
Sundial time is being described in the
terms of clock time which are the given
grounds for comparison
and I would say that much of my project
in this book could be described as me
trying to flip these two both for myself
and for the reader to make material
non-linear signatures of time feel like
what time really is
um so before this talk we watched that
beautiful piece the history of the sky
in the book I write about doing
something similar during the pandemic
because so much of the social
structuring of time was removed or
interrupted my days felt like as I put
in the book boxes of time to be filled
in my box of a room forever and ever
and in response to the stultifying
sameness I pointed a camera out my
window and sporadically took photos of
the sky and I Write Time felt the same
in my room but in the photos it rained
it stormed and the fog rolled in from
San Francisco sometimes the clouds were
enormous and sharply defined other times
distant and wispy midday the sky could
be a deep dark blue in the evening it
would soften to an Indescribable shade
of something like purple or pink
and as I mentioned earlier this chapter
is sort of imaginatively set in
Pescadero
I called the chapter putting time back
in its place
and it draws on the work of geologists
the philosopher Henry bergson and
Indigenous Scholars like fine deloria Jr
and Tyson yucoporta and in all of those
cases what you really sense is the
inseparability of time from space
in this chapter I used the rock layers
of the beach in which time essentially
runs sideways across the beach to
illustrate what the geologist Marcia
bjornerude calls time fullness
she writes I see that the events of the
past are still present this impression
is a glimpse not of timelessness but of
time fullness an acute consciousness of
how the world is made by indeed made of
time
and trying to imagine whatever the
opposite of fungible time is I show the
reader these beach pebbles which uh
happen almost mid-paragraph like Words
um and I write look again at the Pebbles
make no mistake they are neither signs
nor symbols of time no they really are
two things at once sea floor from the
last ice age and Future Sand
so Beach or no beach simply making
everyday observations of what we
consider ecological or geological
reveals how intuitive this concrete
material sense of time Still Remains for
us and in fact I think this is exactly
what happened during the pandemic for
those whose scale of attention shrunk to
their house or their backyard
for example statistics involving birding
number of birding supplies sold number
of observations logged to sites like
eBird and visits to bird webcams show
that many more people became attentive
not only to the Daily movements of birds
but also their migrations
um Karina Newsome an ornithologist and
one of the founders of blackbirders week
noted that spring migration coincided
with the early lockdowns and that it
might be therapeutic to watch the larger
Rhythm that continued to go on
in our Stillness other movements became
more palpable
for me one important clock ended up
being an individual buckeye tree in a
park that I always walk through
this tree grows leaves and flowers in
the spring and goes dormant in the late
summer but that procession is uneven
across the region across a Grove across
the branches of the same tree or across
the surface of a yellowing leaf
the body of the tree itself is also a
record of the past since the Buckeye's
ability to go dormant is an evolutionary
response to a change in the climate
three million years ago
and so I write what is a clock if it's
something that tells the time then my
Branch was a clock but unlike the clock
at home it would never return to its
original position
instead it was a physical witness and a
record of overlapping events some of
which happened long ago and some of
which are still occurring as I write
this
and that's that those images are also in
in the book this is also a text exchange
from last month when my boyfriend was
here and I was in the Santa Cruz
mountains and we're observing that the
clock is the same in both places
um Okay so
what I just described is something that
I described in the book as unfreezing
something in time
um I write if you want to see some time
that isn't fungible just pick a point in
space a branch a yard a sidewalk square
a webcam and simply keep watch a story
is being written there the story is
inseparable from the story of all life
even yours
um and while it might be fascinating and
enlightening enlivening for us to
unfreeze things in time there is also an
ethical Dimension to doing so because to
see something as an as inhabiting time
with you is to consider that it has
experience
while researching for this book I was
really floored by a study on something
called the Lesser Minds problem
um that's a what it sounds like it's a
name for our bias to see the inner lives
of other people especially people we
consider to be in out groups as not not
as complex as our own
and so in one of the experiments people
were asked to consider typically
dehumanized out groups such as drug
addicts or people without housing
ordinarily for those participants
thinking about people in those groups
wouldn't activate regions of the brain
associated with theory of mind
but what the researchers found was that
by simply asking the participants
whether or not a houseless person would
like a certain vegetable those neural
regions became activated
in other words and in my interpretation
the question about the vegetable
presumes a person with preferences and
desires
and desire and attitude for the future
and a reflection of one's past can only
exist in time the time inhabited by that
person
this notion of frozenness or unfrozeness
has broader implications namely
regarding the climate crisis that
increasingly interrupts the human
calendar
just like the concept of time as money
is a political history so too is the
division of who and who does not inhabit
time I.E who has experience and who acts
on the historical stage
the Jamaican theorist Sylvia winter has
written about how the Western notion of
man man versus nature defined man
against colonized people who were
characterized as Timeless backward or
less progress
part part of the similarly Timeless
landscape and in my formulation Frozen
in that same book I mentioned earlier
the colonization of time the author
quotes a letter from the daughter-in-law
of a British missionary in what is now
South Africa in which she writes
you must know that today we have
unpacked our clock and we seem a little
more civilized for some months we have
lived without a timepiece John's
chronometer and my watch have failed and
we have left time and been blanched onto
eternity however it is very pleasing to
hear tick tick tick and ding ding
um for me this suggests an important
connection that the same framing that
has allowed us to juice the supposedly
inert non-experiencing natural world dry
is the same one I mentioned earlier in
which laborers have been Juiced of their
supposedly fungible lifetimes
it also explains why we feel that there
is cultural human time which moves
forward and makes things a natural
non-human time which is cyclical and
insubstantial it's that it's an echo of
that supposed hierarchy of The Eternity
and tick tick tick and ding ding
as Bill McKibben has pointed out the
irony of this conceptual divide is that
what is thought of as human cultural
time actually can't keep up with the
changes in what is thought of as
non-human time
in that vein I argue a lot in this book
for non-human subject hood and that's
one of the reasons I Rely so much on
indigenous scholarship
like those Scholars and like McKibben my
reason is my reasoning is partly
practical I really don't believe that a
true holistic response to either time
scarcity or the climate crisis is
possible without such a change in
perspective
but I also want this for us
both in how to do nothing and in Saving
Time I'm really bothered by this idea
and very much informed by my own
experience of people chasing achievement
but really wanting meaning and
connection among and Beyond the human
these are two little diagrams that I
find myself drawing different versions
of every single year and they maybe give
you a sense of what extension means in
the title of my last chapter life
extension
um that chapter which is really less
about mortality than what it means to me
to be alive starts with a story from a
children's book my mom got from a garage
sale it's haunted me ever since I read
it
um also thanks to my mom for scanning it
um but uh basically a witch visits an
impatient young boy and gives him a ball
with a golden thread and if he pulls the
thread time goes faster
and she advises him to use it wisely as
the thread can't be put in any more than
time can go backward
predictively he pulls it too often and
patient to go home from school impatient
to marry his crush and patient to get a
job
luckily for him and because this is a
children's story The Witch returns to
the old man takes back the ball and lets
him start over again
but in our case no matter how many
dividends our time pays we do not get
that chance
as an answer to this anxiety I Look to
Crypt time a term used in disability
studies to describe the tension between
a disabled person's temporality and the
clock-based industrial timetables of
modern day Society
for someone who fundamentally cannot buy
into the system of thinking because it
was not built for them it is perhaps
easier to imagine the goal of life as
something other than performance and
accumulation
there's a really beautiful chapter on
Crypt time in this book what can a body
do by Sarah hendron one of my favorite
contemporary writers and thinkers in
which she reflects on her experience
Raising a Son with Down Syndrome
the way people equate her son with his
diagnosis in a way seeing him also
outside of time illuminates for Henry
and how economic productivity and a life
lived along normative timetables and
Milestones are so deeply entwined with
the idea of human worth
but her son also demonstrates to her a
different way of being
seeing how Graham her son is categorized
but also seeing his self-understanding
and his sources of joy is what allows
hendren to question everything about
time we've come to take for granted
she asks how long does it take or should
it take for a body to move through the
world the 40-plus Hour Work Week the
demands of caregiving for ailing parents
the daily commute of the body with its
changing needs over the lifespan
a pregnant body an aging one a body in
recovery after a bad injury
is the clock of industrial time built
for bodies at all
the idea of Krypton prepares us to move
from thinking about achievement to
thinking about encounter
I'll never forget the elderly woman who
called in to a radio show I was on
talking about how to do nothing she was
recently disabled and had been sitting
in her backyard watching the birds and
in some cases even having them land on
her and she said it was one of the
happiest times in her life
I too can attest to this phenomenon as a
related experience is almost entirely
responsible for my interest in Birds
something that's now very present in all
of my work in the book I describe a day
in 2013 when I just pulled an
all-nighter on an art project and had
just come home from my day job I was
lying on my couch and mobilized by my
own exhaustion with my eyes pointed up
out the window at the top of a redwood
tree I was so tired that in fact I
thought I was hallucinating pears
growing at the top of the tree until I
realized that they were birds with
yellow bellies all facing into the sun
and this site made my burnout from work
flip over into a different kind of
tiredness
an open mouth State of Wonder that the
PO the poet Peter Hancock calls
tiredness that trusts in the world
what I had seen were cedar waxwings who
are locally nomadic and follow the
fruiting of berries an expression of
time in their own way
the site was a Gateway for me that has
remained open ever since I write I
remember that Vision on the couch so
clearly not just because it was the
beginning of an abiding interest in
birds and their territories
in a more General sense I remember it as
a kind of opening onto Infinity through
that opening I saw something else
someone else beckoning from a different
version of time and space where Suburban
Gardens far-flung wintering grounds
summer and winter were all intertwined
and I I later go on to suggest that
maybe the point isn't to live more in
the literal sense of a longer or more
productive life but rather to be more
alive in any given moment a movement
across rather than shooting forward on a
narrow lonely track
um and on that note there's something I
think is implied in a lot of this book
but that I regret isn't said more
outright and which I think is especially
appropriate to mention here at the long
now
I am very fortunate to have a handful of
friends in their 60s and 70s I am also
fortunate to be friends with a couple of
my own former students and the more time
I spend with these friends the more I
let go of the idea that generational
concerns are inherently unrelated
yes things have changed yes in this
country older Generations hold much of
the wealth but I think an over emphasis
on generational barriers makes it less
obvious how people in every group might
Harbor values that have cut across time
in history and it obscures some of the
possibilities that come with a
collective memory and a set of
experiences that are longer than any of
our individual lifetimes
in the chapter of my book on communal
languages of time
I quote quite a bit from process World a
magazine active in the 80s and 90s that
was started by a group of San Francisco
temp workers concerned about the
alienation of modern work and life
and what I especially love is the
letters section which acts almost like a
Proto Message Board allowing readers to
discover each other and the idea that
they are not alone in their
dissatisfaction the so-called honor of
getting to sell the hours of your life
for something so meaningless
one of the letters starts out jump into
Jehoshaphat there's intelligent life out
there
and I think this kind of Discovery can
happen not just across space but across
time
my friend Chris Carlson one of the
editors of process world
recently wrote in an essay about his
hopes in the 1980s for the magazine
adding our ideas in our community that
shared our sensibility didn't really
grow much perhaps our role was to carry
a radical thread from the decades that
preceded us to the decades that would
follow
I was so excited by this sentence that I
immediately emailed Chris to tell him
how I'd woven process World quotes
together with contemporary organizing
among International gig workers but also
how I expected my readers including a
fair share of people younger than me to
easily recognize both the fury and the
sense of humor that comes through in
process world
that's what I saw as my role and it
would be impossible not only with these
past Expressions but with institutions
like the internet archive and the
prolinger library who make them
available to the present
I think the most important technology
we've ever had is the story but stories
only work through the telling
so I'm just going to end by reading an
excerpt from that same chapter that
process World shows up in and just to
give a little bit of context because it
comes up in the excerpt I use a term
familict which I learned about from my
friend Helen who is also the person who
gave me the cactus uh Pig
um so a family just means a specific
words or phrases that are used hyper
locally within a small group of people
so it's like a dialect but even smaller
um okay
earlier this year I was in the garden of
a septuagenarian friend while she was
planting some beans
she told me that they were descended
from Beans she'd gotten 20 years before
from somewhere she couldn't quite
remember maybe Home Depot I could never
find again
at the time she'd shared the beans with
friends all of whom loved them and
couldn't find them anywhere else either
but some friends let the bean pods
mature and dry out saving the beans and
giving them back to her she had no idea
how many people had them by now and
speculated that this line of beans could
have spread across the entire country
as she planted them we used that
although there had been a give and take
between her and her friends it was not
exactly transactional she wasn't taking
back the things she had given them
though the two were certainly related
she moved on to some lettuce beds
telling me I should take some lettuce I
thought she was just being polite but
she told me that she actually needed to
get rid of the outside leaves so the
inside leaves would keep growing before
the plant reached maturity she was
constantly giving bags of lettuce to
people she said
this simple gesture and the story of the
beans made me realize how broken my
mental mechanisms were for thinking
about anything beyond the transactional
exchange
in part this is because I've never lived
anywhere I could Garden I'd sort of
forgotten that a plant keeps growing
assuming that more lettuce for leaves
for me would mean fewer lettuce leaves
for her
but it wasn't the only thing I'd
forgotten
philosopher Ivan illick worried in 1978
that quote innumerable sets of
infrastructures in which people coped
played eight made friends and loved have
been destroyed leaving a Barren social
landscape of huge zero-sum games
monolithic Delivery Systems in which
every gain for one turns into a loss or
burden for another while true
satisfaction is denied to both
in that moment I felt not dissimilar to
the young gig worker who told
sociologists in a study of why
precarious workers didn't claim
unemployment benefits during the
pandemic in New York City
you just sign up and say I don't have a
job and the government gives you money
what is that about if it was that easy
wouldn't everybody do it I don't get it
taking the lettuce was good for both me
and my friend I didn't get it
a few months later I was sitting in a
different Garden this time a botanical
garden with free admission
two kids had taken over a long lawn next
to me and were playing a game of red
light green light their version of it
however was considerably more complex
than the one I played as a kid
red light still meant stop and green
light still meant go
but for them purple light meant to dance
light blue light meant to dance backward
Golden Light meant to fall on the ground
and green tree light meant to moo and
crawl at the same time
it was silly but I was impressed that
they never had to remind one another
what any of the terms meant they had
created and memorized them together
time can have many rhythms and rhythms
can take on many meanings writing about
the demoralization of work through
processes like taylorism sociologist
Richard Senate has observed that routine
can demean but it can also protect
routine can decompose labor but it can
also compose a life
it can be the construction of a ritual
the way that the Rabbi Abraham Joshua
heschel called the Sabbath a palace that
we build in time
like the lights of red light green the
like the lights of the red light green
light game the Botanical Garden had been
composed and choreographed different
spots had different characters things
grew in different shapes and sizes and
flowered at different times the garden
represented one Gardener's one set of
gardeners views about what kinds of
Arrangements would make up a harmonious
whole and visitors lingered in the parts
that they liked
while it wasn't a large space the garden
was dense a space Not Just of
biodiversity but of Chrono diversity
inviting the human subject into
conversations with different modes and
speeds of life
here it was not only clear that time was
not money but that the category of not
money could be infinitely elaborated
would it be possible to not to save and
spend time but to Garden it by Saving
inventing and stewarding different
rhythms of life
and wouldn't this simply be an
acknowledgment and use of the Chrono
diversity that already exists for all of
us on some level individually and
communally
the sociologist Barbara Adam who has
written about standardized economic time
also knows that its dominance is as
incomplete as it is unintuitive she
writes Tempo and intensity surround us
at every level we know that a birthday
tomorrow can feel like an eternity to a
little child while a birthday one year
ago can seem Like Only Yesterday to an
old person
the dormant period of winter is followed
by a burst of growth in Spring our
social time as it emerges from common
usage is insufferable from The rhythms
of the earth complexity Reigns Supreme
if time can be gardened then it's also
possible to imagine its increase in ways
other than individual hoarding
before I left my friend's Garden she
gave me some Scarlet runner beans from a
bean farm that no longer exists
they're now sitting on a metal shelf
next to the store-bought beans that Joe
and I like many other people started
stocking up on during the pandemic
I've had so much time to look at and
think about beans but I had never
considered what they actually were
I Googled can you plant store-bought
beans and the answer was yes those
things in the bags they weren't just
Commodities sure you could eat them but
they weren't end points and they weren't
dead at least some of them contained
something the possibility of future
beans
as I told more friends about this story
it became an inside joke a new family
time is not money time is beans
it was about as serious as many it was
as serious as many jokes are which is to
say about half
saying it meant that you could take time
and give time but also that you could
plant time and grow more of it and that
there were different varieties of time
it meant that all your time grew out of
someone else's time maybe out of
something someone planted long ago
it meant that time was not the currency
of a zero-sum game and that sometimes
the best way for me to get more time
would be to give it to you and the best
way for you to get some would be to give
it back to me
if time were not a commodity then time
our time would not be as scarce as it
seemed just a moment ago
together we could have all the time in
the world
thanks
[Applause]
thank you so much
um I think the rest of you can kind of
see how when I started reading this book
I couldn't stop underlining things it's
uh it's so perfect for I think our
audience and a really great way to start
uh
the the first talk back in in this
theater for this group and I I love the
way it ended there it kind of redefines
what a bean counter is in this
mechanized version of human and
commodified time so it's yeah it's
perfect uh a perfect thing and I I just
I wanted to kind of loop back around to
just the way that you work and and you
you were kind of holding still and
observing around you long before the
rest of us were forced to
um yeah and um how did you how do you
think you came to this idea of of
observing the things that are closest to
us
question
this is a very weird answer but my my
mom um my mom does respite care for
foster families which is basically like
your designated babysitter and she says
that she's noticed something with the
babies that she takes care of that was
also true of me which is that she said
if you push the stroller next to a shrub
like the babies will just like they'll
just get in it you know like they want
to grab it and like put their face in
the shrub you know
um and I think like when I was like
really little my mom actually just
noticed that I liked like I was happier
if I was outside
um like just looking at stuff like
things that were very immediate and she
was always taking me to live theater
that she wanted me to be in theater
um
um but please run off and join the
circus yeah
um so I think like I like I think it
just goes way back like I think I grew
up like largely thanks to her like with
the assumption that there's going
there's something interesting in front
of you like I just assumed that like I
don't feel like I need to like wait for
it you know yeah we've also been taking
care of a little baby and like babies
are a perfect naturalist and we just
kind of beat it out of them for the rest
of their lives yeah I know it's funny
because I I think I I said in an
interview recently that like the last
time people many people like remember
the sense of curiosity that like I am
clearly obsessed with is childhood but
then later I was thinking about it like
that's not true I have friends who have
children and I think you've
re-experience it through children yeah
yeah watching them watch the world is
kind of one of the most magic things
yeah I just want to remind you all that
we do have the question cards and there
are uh long now people going up and down
I have some of them up here but uh
Mika's sorting them and he's going to
bring some up to me but I'm going to
continue to keep us started here for a
little bit and also the people on the
live stream are writing in questions and
uh those are being transcribed and
brought down as cards as well
um you know I've always as long as I've
worked on this project uh about time and
I've kind of shied away from dealing
with time from from the front like the
way you have and it's always kind of so
daunting to me
um and so I'm just I'm I'm wondering how
how you decided that it was it was it
was something that you could take on and
uh it's like it's just it's always so
daunting to me yeah it
is why didn't I read a book about
and I know that I would find a way to
make that really come so like like yeah
um I so um if anyone here has read how
to do nothing there's a part of how to
do well there's a part of how to do
nothing where I mentioned being in a
cabin with no reception and this and I
didn't um really notice this until I
found my notes way later what I was
doing in that cabin was I was writing
the I was trying to write the proposal
for how to do nothing while I was in the
cabin and I found it and I had divided
the paper into and it was how to do
nothing in space and how to do nothing
in time
and then I think I just completely
forgot about like that like structure or
maybe I just I you know I think the way
it turned out ended up being much more
about space because there's a lot of
bioregionalism and sort of like local
ecology in that book so in a way I think
maybe it was just kind of like
a seed that just didn't really it was
just there for a while
um and then
so those ideas were there and then after
how to do nothing came out like a lot of
feedback that I heard had to do with
time like people who were like I agree
with these ideas but I don't like what
am I supposed to do about the time I
don't have time
um and I like I really didn't like that
really bothered me because I like it
didn't have a good answer to that
um and so I think that that combined
with like what that that sort of seed
from earlier kind of those things came
together
it's also just like I think I
similarly to observing things like I
think I like to write about things that
are very immediate like
combining you know things that are that
are from you know academic disciplines
and like other research with just like
the things that you experience every day
or the things that I experience every
day and so like time is just very
familiar it's like you can't get away
from it and so I think it appeals for
that reason
yeah yeah and I think you know it's
interesting like
at least before the pandemic you'd often
ask people you know how are they doing
and the answer is always some form of
I'm really busy
um and this kind of fetishization with
being overly busy
um and I think the idea that you have
kind of given people an excuse to to not
want to be busy uh and that slowing down
is actually a and how and giving
yourself the time and obviously having
the privilege to have that time
um which I think you mentioned in the
book too that time can often be a
privilege as well but um can you say a
little bit more about our personal time
and and and our the way that we think
about it that way yeah
um so in that same chapter where I talk
about the increasing personal efficiency
book with the amazing weather map
um and the productivity Bros
um I I um something that I found very
useful in writing that and that's
mentioned in the chapter is this
um there's a paper by the sociologist
Hartman Rosa where he describes a
hypothetical character named Linda
um and Linda is um like a she's a
university professor she's
um she's very busy she's always she's
described she's running around she
doesn't have enough time for her
students she's gonna have enough time
for her colleagues she doesn't have
enough time to like make dinner go to
the gym and like she just feels like a
failure because she's always running out
of time and then and he says like the
only way that she would um experience
like peace is if she went to a cabin
with no reception
um and and I was like reading this and
feeling and then he says isn't this all
kind of her fault though like didn't she
bring this on herself and I felt like so
like attacked by this
um because I was like I'm Linda
um and so like I I kind of like use that
to like make this distinction between
like Linda's and non-lindas but then
there's like a gray area but I I think
it's a really I think that's kind of
what people were trying to get at like
when they were responding to how to do
nothing there's a difference between
someone who truly has no control over
their time and someone who feels like
they have no time and again I really
like there is a gray area but like the
you know for someone who actually
structurally doesn't have control over
their time like the answer does not lie
with them using their time better
like as the working mom admin like you
know was telling me
um but then there's like another
situation where you just have someone
who's deeply internalized that like
busyness is good
um and that like more like you just need
more all the time you always need to be
getting more more friends more
achievements like more you know
um and that Linda character like needs
to just chill like basically go to the
cabin yeah yeah I think I I would say
like experiment with what feels like
mediocrity
yeah yeah
yeah I mean I think what's amazing is
you know time has become you know it's
both the most valuable commodity that we
have and it's also the most easy to
waste or at least what we call wasting
right and so this
um you mentioned banking time and the
way that also the way that Western
cultures native cultures and plants and
animals you know may or may not follow
Gregorian calendars or or 12-hour time
but I wonder if you could talk a little
bit more about the way other cultures
and animals are perceiving time
yeah I mean I think it's just like it's
almost like
you like when you look at like the
history of how time became standardized
and and like the idea of like the man
hour and all that it's so narrow like
when you actually look at the history of
it so like contingent that it's sort of
like everything else around that
um it just starts to look like a little
sliver instead of like the sort of the
norm and then there's like this exotic
way of like seeing time you know like
it's actually the Exotic way of seeing
time
um and so I think like something that I
really admired in the examples
um that I drew from Sand talk which is
the book by Tyson yonkaporta and also
examples from find deloria Jr are like
there's this um really Exquisite sense
of timing which I think is like a very
interesting to contrast timing with like
the idea of uniform time like timing
suggests that there's a right time that
so not all time is the same already and
then there's a there's a best time to do
something and so like I think you know
obviously in indigenous cultures there's
like a deep intent as to like what is
happening at any given moment and like
you have to do this thing at this time
and the way that you know this that this
is going to happen is that this other
thing is going to happen and they're all
just like so deeply intertwined it's
sort of like everything is a clock
almost
um and so I think like that's
uh that feels much more I don't know
like it's real it's it's based on things
that are actually like materially
happening in the world it's not abstract
at all
yeah yeah yeah so I mean you mentioned
in that in the book I think a lot of
what of natural versions of time you put
that the equation of time which is you
know the difference of solar to Absolute
time which you also had to deal with in
the 10 000 year clock because it was
synchronized to the sun and it was just
in India and saw the largest sundial in
the world where they was built in order
to be so large that it had it was had
two second accuracy which I thought was
like the most kind of dichotomous thing
you talk about sundials is this kind of
beautiful way of slowing time down in a
way but the idea that somebody had them
tried to make it the most accurate time
device uh was hilarious to me yeah yeah
yeah
um we'll start to get to some of the
audience questions here
um
Raul asks uh what do you make of the
hypothesis made by prominent physicists
that time and space do not exist but
maybe an illusion
[Laughter]
that's very interesting
they think that I
um
uh there's
um there's a poet who I quote in the
book who's a friend of mine John chapter
who has a book of poetry coming out
um later this year and so I've been
reading those poems and um this is a
roundabout way of saying that um like
it's called near Earth object I'm gonna
plug the book um but the it's as you can
maybe tell from the title it's it's very
much um like this insistence on like
earthliness and like what it means to be
Earthly and so I guess like
my answer to that is like I live in time
and space yeah like as as a human animal
so like I am going to you know like that
that's what matters to me yeah
um like
what the actual like nature of that like
that's I find that fascinating but I
guess like my concern is like a lot like
closer to home yeah yeah yeah
time exists for you yeah yeah like and
it's embodied like I can I will only
ever be able to understand it in like a
human embodied way
yeah I think one of the things that you
you also get to is this idea that of
different cycles of you know geologic
time or or climate time you mentioned
and I think one of the the problems that
we humans have with thinking about
things like the climate crisis is that
there's they're out of scale with what
we have been taught to value in terms of
time as being much faster moving or much
more proximate but I wonder if you could
talk a little bit about that
yeah
um I mean I I talk about uh that
horrible day uh with the red sky which
I'm sure many of us remember
um in chapter five and uh and this that
I I kept having these nightmares about
like a wall of Fire coming and then it
was like it was very uniform the way
that it moved it was like
it's coming for you it's like it's it's
like it's a like a video play hedge just
going and there's nothing you can do
about it and that's a very like linear
and uh like declinist way of looking at
it that I definitely had
um and so I think
one of the you know as I kind of tried
to like pick that apart in that chapter
I really came to appreciate the
different scales that everything related
to climate happens on like some things
happen very quickly some things happen
very slowly some things are hyper local
some things are widespread and some
things can go backwards like things can
be restored you know like things can
also like locally get better
um and so like when you like it just
really helped me to stop seeing it as
this like
you know and like and just kind of like
consider myself as like always every day
being in the midst of it like every day
just wake up I'm in the midst of it I
have to respond and like that's it it's
just day after day yeah
um less yeah I believe it is uh asks
um how does your relationship a time
that you kind of point out as deep as
you're reading is kind of deep and
complex influence the other
relationships in your life
um so it's how does one really strange
effect
um which I did not expect at all which
is that I for most of my life until
recently have identified as a loner
um like I was definitely felt that way
as a teenager it's like writing in my
giant Journal you know like everywhere
um and just like very Daria kind of
Vibes um
and uh and then I just kind of carry
that with me and I um and anyone here
who's a perfectionist knows that there's
something very isolating about
perfectionism it's like you alone you
gotta you have to do it all yourself and
it has to be perfect
um and I think as I as a weird side
effect of me talking about you know not
wanting to be my time in your time and
our time
um I recently realized that I am no
longer a loner like I I don't I'm not
saying that like I'm around people more
necessarily like maybe I am but but I
don't identify as a loner anymore I own
I identify as like a piece of different
relationships with different people and
I feel much less
um
selfish about my time like uh even if
I'm like working on something like I
just realized like how much of the work
gets done in conversations with people
and so I feel like I I really let that
idea of it not being a zero-sum game
like it really
affected me and like I I don't I don't
see myself as this like isolated thing
anymore right yeah well and I love how
you talk about how you know traveling uh
you know through the Circuit of the Bay
Area is can be tied to the stories that
you tell and I remember the story of
native storytelling where somebody was
in the back of a pickup truck and then
the natives who are in the back of the
truck kept starting stories and then
starting a new one because the truck was
moving much faster than a human would
yeah and so they couldn't they couldn't
separate the time and the in the space
yeah because you need the landmarks to
correct tell the story yeah so it's kind
of you did the same thing in your book
which it was really beautiful yeah it
did and that was like I knew about those
kinds of examples and I also uh
um the partner of the person who gave me
the lettuce
um he and I went on a really long walk
one time in the town in the Santa fe's
mountains we have this amazing
conversation it was very long and I I
wish that I could take notes oh that
would be weird weird to do but
um I I realize I could remember it later
if I just went on the walk in my head
yeah so I was like let's just do that
yeah that's the old trick yeah
um let's get apropos for this next
question
um do you have any inner conflict with
living in a city uh if so share a bit
about how you reconcile the kind of
beauty of being at a cabin with no
reception but also
clearly you're you're so very tied to
Urban culture as well yeah
um I think that I that would be a really
big problem for me if I lived in maybe
any other city
um I live in Oakland uh
yeah uh and I remember actually when I
started birding I've looked at a map it
was a book of maps of California a
different
um
like species diversity of like different
groups of species um and so there was
one that was like bird diversity and it
was all so clustered like it was the the
color it was like very dark um in in
Oakland
um and I remember like realizing that
because I had no context I just thought
that there were this many birds
everywhere
um but like no I just like sort of came
into awareness like in a place that
happens to have a lot of birds
um and so part of the reason I like I I
sort of reconciled for me is that I live
somewhere that has
you know it has parks and there's just
like a lot I like when I get asked if I
go bird watching I I don't go bird
watching I'm just always bird watching
because if I leave my apartment I will
see birds like I see lots of birds so I
saw them today like you know
um so I think uh you know I like to make
my occasional trip to the mountains
um which we're also very fortunate to
live like pretty close to the Santa Cruz
mountains
so I've gotten or I've gotten around
that problem that way I think I I don't
know I don't know what I would do if I
live somewhere else I can't move
nice and I think you know I mean the
other thing that we have here in the Bay
Area is obviously this kind of uh and
even some of the founders of long now or
uh some of the people that helped design
the first spreadsheets and things that
you kind of mentioned in here that have
driven us into kind of commodification
of time and obviously the the culture of
the way we run companies here is is also
about
um not only compress compressing time
but also this idea that there's an
infinite scaling that's possible
um but I I think you get to this a
little bit and kind of the that's we
can't just scale everything in all
directions as as humans all the time and
we have to kind of pick a right size of
things
um so I wonder if you talk a little bit
about that yeah I mean I just I um
there's a I think it's Daniel Wildcat
who's an indigenous author that I cite
in the putting time back in its place
chapter
um where he he's sort of one he says
that he wonders like what
what would happen if we were more aware
of the personality of places that like
each place has a personality
um and as someone who grew up in um San
Jose like Cupertino San Jose with lots
of uh Anonymous shopping centers
um like that where everything sort of
like all of the difference seems to have
been paved over I recognize that it's
like hard
um in some places to see the personality
or the character of a place but I am
very enchanted with this idea that no
place is the same like the same way that
no moment is the same like no place is
the same and so I think there's like
some and that that's what gives meaning
to a place and so I think like anything
that anything that can allow us to be
more attentive to that and kind of
collect things around
the the characteristics and the
personalities of places is very
compelling to me yes
um here's what it's uh coming right up
on us uh Emma asks what do you think of
the bi-annual time change
oh I hate it yeah
um
there's oh my gosh what is it called
okay well it's in chapter six there's I
I have a block quote from a book about
daylight savings that is that book is so
funny you should all read it it's
hilarious I got it on sale I was like oh
I guess I should like read about
daylight savings and then it was I was
just like laughing out loud the whole
time I was reading this book because
it's so farcical this history of
daylight savings in the US is just so
ridiculous like I can't even just you
should just check out the book but
um it's it really it really highlights
the arbitrariness of it and like those
sort of like questionable interests
um that were involved in establishing
daylight savings um and I obviously as a
result of writing the book like I have
more respect for
um like bodily time
um and like these kind of like uh
material like rhythms and like I just
see something like daily things is just
interrupting that like why am I gonna
now my body's just gonna be off like for
like no good reason anybody with a baby
would agree with you yeah it's like all
of a sudden the baby's like yeah I'm
getting up when yeah it's so it's so
disruptive yeah
uh and Kristen asks uh
what do you see as part of composing and
driving the human compulsion to capture
times this kind of goes back to your
previous book of that we seem to want to
Capture Moments in time with cameras and
and making a tweet about a thing rather
than just sitting there and experiencing
it
um yeah I mean
I think that as a
I think it's very understandable it's
like time is always slipping through
your fingers you want to grab onto it
like what could be more human than that
you know
um I mean as someone who
uh has always written a lot in a journal
since I was a child I have at times
asked myself like if I should just stop
writing and go outside and like do the
things that are then being written about
like like what's the what's the like
yeah what's the Divide there
um and Barbara aaronreich who wrote
natural causes I can't remember the
subtitle but it's really good it's like
killing ourselves to live longer
epidemic of Wellness that's a long
really good subtitle and it's a grim
reaper running on a treadmill
um
my uh my agent told me that she wanted
originally to call it old enough to die
and they wouldn't but
um that wasn't gonna fly off the shelves
is that phrase somewhere
kind of examination of that like what is
the calculus it's like how much time
should you put into
trying to have more time you know and
like at what point like you know don't
you need to eventually ask the question
of like what it's all for right
um and so I think like that's I just
think it's very natural like I have that
like you everyone want if you're
especially if you're like enjoying your
life you like want more of it and you
want to
have more of it like have more like
evidence of it and it's there's
something very Bittersweet about the
idea of having a really lovely
experience that's just going to be over
like it's just going to be gone and like
you don't have anything yeah but then at
the same time that gives it so much
meaning so yeah
yeah
um this is a good segue into Noah's
question which is uh has researching for
and writing this book changed your
feelings around aging and mortality now
your last chapter is kind of about this
to some extent yeah yeah it is
um
yeah I mean it doesn't make me like it
doesn't
it doesn't make me less
uh afraid of my own death because
um I but I do think that
um
it has and it's it's partially as a
result of writing this book but also as
I mentioned having friends who are older
um like it has allowed me to like rest
more in the time that I'm in like the
part of the my life that I'm in because
like you know the my lettuce French is
twice my age
um and like I see her see where I am and
she just sees all this time in front of
me and like I just feel like it's today
and I need you know and I'm probably
thinking about like the past week and
maybe the next week you know but like
she sees me as like situated in the
middle of something and then if I see
myself from her perspective I'm like oh
I need to really
like live this because I'm not gonna get
another chance you know yeah
well that's I I have another question
that's along that lines of you know what
what nuggets of Hope might you give to
individuals stuck and Paralyzed by the
isolation and individualization uh which
is reinforced to us in the way that kind
of time has forced on us at this point
yeah um
I mean I like I said those diagrams that
I showed I I draw I feel like I draw
them over and over again I always think
it's a different diagram but it's the
same one
um and I think that
if you it's hard
uh because everything about our culture
really wants to reinforce the boundaries
around yourself
but if you can try to like let go of
that
um and really like shift your focus from
these like supposed individual entities
to ties between them like what happens
when you're with a friend and like you
you and friend combined like that is
something in and of itself
um and there's there's an exchange
that's happening in there like the B you
know the beans going back and forth
um I think like things like asking for
help it's like just if you're you're
having a problem as an individual and
you ask someone for help like that is
in in the zero-sum like kind of zerosome
game view that's you're asking someone
to give you
some like they'll have less but that is
actually how most like friendships are
built is like you ask someone for help
and they help you and they want to help
you and like it's understood that you
will then help them so I think like try
it's hard like I said it's we're so you
know
um used to thinking of like not wanting
to you know bother other people or like
I'm just gonna like handle my stuff and
like you handle your stuff but I think
if you kind of start to think like what
what um is possible between me and blank
like other person like place you know
well I think you get to this in a lot of
ways
um this idea of maybe an attention
economy that's different than an empathy
economy
um where you know it's less about how
much attention we can get for ourselves
or give to something but more about how
much empathy and and feeling we can give
it to something but that was kind of one
of the things that struck me as reading
this just like hit me really hard like
yeah we need more empathy and less
trying to argue over attention yeah I
mean just think about the difference
between
like getting a lot of engagement on a
post online versus like your friend
wrote you a letter
and you sit down and you read the letter
it's from one person yeah you know like
that feels so different
um and it's like and it's because they
wrote it for you
um it's it's like I had I had a friend
make me a podcast once which is just for
me
it was great you know
um what a luxurious thing yeah it had a
whole part of the end that was just like
birds in Prospect Park like exactly
um yeah yeah Ah that's beautiful
um right I think you know your kind of
definition of time that you mentioned at
the beginning that you know it's this
thing that bubbles up and and it's all
around us and rather than a thing that
we're that is washing over us or moving
past us
um I think it's a liberating way to
think about time in a lot of ways it
gives it gives people a lot more freedom
I think yeah and I do think it works
against that isolation um
quote in chapter four from from Henry
bergson who's talking about
um he's describing walking through a
city that he has been in for many years
and it's familiar to him and then he
sort of has this realization that
everything that he's seeing around him
has also aged and he says like like you
know he's describing the things and he
says like like me they have aged and I
like I think about that sentence like so
often like when I'm looking around like
that you're that if everything is Frozen
in time except for you or for humans or
the humans you care about
um that's a very lonely existence it's
like the other things aren't speaking
back to you they're not
with you in time but if everything you
know everything like you has aged
um and it's all aging together and it's
you know everything is affecting
everything else like that's that's not
lonely to me even if I'm alone right
nice well I'm going to have one last
question but I do want to remind
everyone that your book is uh for sale
up here and you've pre-signed them all
we we are going to ask um please don't
come up and ask for personal
inscriptions and also just give Jenny a
little bit of space uh at the end
because she is about to embark on a
bunch of travel and we don't want her to
get sick but all the all the books are
already signed so please do grab one
um I I know that you will all really
enjoy the book but um to kind of wrap up
um I I know that you are probably
daunted by the fact that your book just
came out today and it's really great
seeing how much praise it's getting and
that you're probably going to be asked
to give lots and lots of talks like this
so we're so glad to have you at the
beginning of it but I'm wondering if you
uh if you have thoughts on on already on
maybe what you're going to be working on
next
yeah so it's uh another thing that kind
of naturally grows out of the last thing
you can't there's no way that you can
think that much about time and not end
up thinking about memory but memory is
not really it's not really treated in
the book I mean I am sort of arguing
that like rocks have memory and like you
know experience is memory but
um but memory specifically is very
interesting to me now and also what
counts as memory like I'm reading a
re-reading uh Ed Young's book right now
um an immense World which is about
animal senses and he has this
description of uh what it's like to be a
dog and that there's all these there's
there's a record of all these the dog is
basically reading like texts in the form
of smell of all the things that have
happened and so it's like the air is
just crisscrossed with these memories
right like they're not human memories so
I I think like the sort of a memory as a
trace like and the fact that there are
traces of things happening everywhere
that's what's currently interesting to
me nice well you you did a great job of
painting time as a palace in this book
and that I think I would I can't wait to
get into the Memory Palace with you so
thank you so much thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you